looking to get back on track after it so
so debuted down in kansas city last week
got him with a fastball two away
good fastball by jake right there
solaire couldn't catch up and ian
kennedy will make his first start since
the end of the 2018 season
then comes a breaking ball and
beautifully thrown outside corner strike
three called
so max kepler
locked up by that breaking ball couldn't
pull the trigger
strike three
fastball taken for the second strikeout
for jayco de rizzi if he gets that pitch
right there he is going to be tough
today that is that is a difficult pitch
to handle
takes a walk
[Music]
oh yeah good fastball with late life
breaking away and kennedy strikes out
his second tough to strike that guy out
keeps looking back on man how did i miss
that i couldn't file it off that's
because it had that great late life to
it call that
action and here comes byron buxton
fastball up and away and a swing and a
miss and down goes buxton and down go
the twins
coming up
swung out and missed another strikeout
for jayco de rizzi
good fastball here moving away from
monday 94 miles an hour starts as a
strike keeps moving off the plate
[Music]
strike three and order rizzy nine up
nine downs but the royals now countering
with gabe speier so here's polanco
doubled his last time up
lefty spire
delivers that balls into right center
field not gonna be caught
be cut off by nope cut under the glove
of murfield and now it's going to be
picked up by hunter dozier in right
field
and polanco has a stand-up double
i get an error on that it looked like
murfield had a chance to
field it and just scoot it under his
glove
zuber on the mound he'll pitch to nelson
cruz with polanco at second and two down
a drive to left field it won't matter
[Applause]
off the facing of the third deck
and crews puts the twins up two to
nothing
man that it
[Music]
i
i see that and it just
it makes me all grunt out loud i mean
it's just like oh
that is just the classic power swing and
he just hit a laser
five strikeouts for order izzy two two
on the way just wanna miss chased
poor swing right there
strikeout number six nothing but
fastballs and sliders then he drops a
slower
breaking ball right on just off the
outside corner
chase strike three striking out in his
first at bat
runner goes there's a line driving to
right field ceno's going to advance to
third base as dozier gets the ball back
in so good piece of hitting there
so twins have first and third with one
out
a high fly
to left field
gordon has a good arm so no
will tag
and gordon's throw appropriately going
to second base so bunsen with a deep fly
ball to left sacrifice five twins in
front now three to nothing jake utter
rizzy's been outstanding
hit well to right field slicing into the
corner
and a slide and a miss by kepler
and it is a foul ball
oh wait a minute whoa
couldn't tell from that other angle and
the royals are going to challenge that
oh nice
yep so we're gonna leave him at second
base yeah they got smile on his face now
he's pumped
mcbroom is at second base with nobody
out franco
standing in now the o2 breaking ball hit
well left field that's way back there
and that is gone it's a two run homer
for the royals third baseman mike
alfrunk who is fifth homer on the season
that was on an o2 pitch on top of
everything else a hanging curveball in
an o2 pitch odor is he certainly not
happy with himself nelson cruz
this one hit well to left gordon going
back at the wall leaps
and can't make the play he gathers it in
with cruz going to second with a double
the twins are going to challenge us to
see whether the ball left the ballpark
and it did not
i think it's going to be a double
yeah
but it was close so here's rosario to
bat that's a big run out at second base
hit down the right field line might be
trouble not going to be caught if it
goes into the corner and it's fair going
to one hop the wall rosario into second
cruz scores and rosario slides in with a
two out double twins add on now up four
to two taylor rogers is on to pitch
her to third
out at second relay to first double play
around the horn to gone
[Music]
well this is a big moment for alex
undergoes the payoff strike three called
and the twins win the game
gordon strikes out looking
and the twins win 4-2
[Music]